we start in india where at least 18
people were killed and more than a
hundred injured when a passenger plane
skidded off the runway
in the southern city of corricode the
air india express flight from dubai was
carrying
190 passengers and crew heavy monsoon
rain appears to have had a role in the
crash
eyewitnesses described the plane's
fuselage breaking apart as it fell into
a valley some 10 meters below
the boeing 737 flight from dubai was
repatriating
indian citizens stranded by the
coronavirus pandemic
a disastrous outcome for passengers that
had waited months to fly home and
reunite with their families
among the victims were the two pilots as
well as at least one young child
i found a child under a box on the plane
as soon as i picked her up her head had
serious injuries
small child one and a half years old i
took the child in the car
if she was in the ambulance maybe she
could have been saved
i took her to the hospital but she died
[Music]
the remaining passengers and crew
rescued from the rubble are being
treated at several hospitals in the city
many are in critical condition
[Music]
indian prime minister modi tweeted his
condolences to the families of the
victims
heavy rain has battered the area in
recent days and may have caused the
aircraft to overshoot the runway
officials say that whilst rescue
operations are
over they fear the death toll could rise
well joining us now from the indian
capital delhi is dw correspondent amisha
jaiswal
namisha do we know anything more about
the condition of those injured in the
crash
well anthony at least 18 deaths have
already been reported
after rescue operations took over three
hours and all the passengers were
evacuated
dozens of passengers have also been
injured and at least 15 of these
are seriously injured according to
reports from the police
on the ground now these fish these
injured
victims have been taken to hospitals in
corigote itself as well as the
neighboring town
of malappuram now rescue operations say
that despite the nature of the crash
one of the reasons why the facilities
have not been higher
is because the plane did not catch fire
possibly because of the heavy rains that
caused the accident
and thoughts pretty naturally turn to
how and why the accident happened now
what are the
initial thoughts of those in charge of
the investigation
well actually it seems that the kind of
runway could have been
a main factor on why this accident
happened these runways are called table
top runways which basically
are formed like a plateau investigative
investigators are already saying that
perhaps
it was the rain which caused the plane
to spill off this runway
into the valley which was a 35 feet drop
and
an accident of this feature has also
taken place before in another similar
hilltop runway
in india itself 10 years ago in 2010 158
people lost their lives
in a crash in very similar circumstances
but of course
the ministry of aviation has ordered an
investigation
the black boxes have already been
retrieved and more information will keep
emerging
namisha jaiswal with the latest from
india thank you so much
you